hey guys but the new rockstars I'm Sam
Bosch are here with yet another MC Yuri
watch breakdown here with the final
chapter of MCU phase 2 campaign so
here's your spoiler warning for ant-man
the movie all the Ant Man comics span
the Avengers comics in the Avengers
movies guys you know the joy let's get
going with comic book Easter eggs my
favorite okay get off with ant-man the
name of the movie and our main hero for
this flick he first appeared in tales to
astonish number 27 in January 1962 but
originally it was Hank Pym not Scott
Lang wish you guys can kind of tell
based on the history inside of this
movie in the MCU now originally Hank is
a scientist who created the Pym particle
which is basically the same as it is in
the MCU is a size changing formula
basically but Hank did take on a few
different personas in the Marvel
Universe ant-man giant man yellow jacket
yes yellow jacket was a hero
sometimes Goliath and even wasp yes wasp
the same character that his wife you
know took that persona of it was strange
he went through a lot
Hank is also well known in the comics
for creating Ultron the villain of the
second Avengers film now in the movie
they kind of touch on the darker side of
Hank Pym he's not always the most
mentally stable guy in the comics he's
infamously known for hitting his wife
which actually win that comic was
written there's actually a
miscommunication between the artist and
the writer that wasn't really supposed
to meant to happen that was supposed to
be just a push but it's turned into a
slap no it's not great I'm not a fan of
it and that actually leads to the reason
that Scott is the main and ant-man in
the MCU I'm a fan of that also scott has
a more interesting backstory in my
opinion but it's worth bringing up also
it's worth mentioning that he was
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby which
we actually had a fund not to Jack Kirby
later on in this movie also worth
mentioning that he and his wife Janet
the ant-man and the wasp were founding
members of The Avengers not Hawkeye and
Black Widow
now in this intro scene we see IAD aged
Michael Douglas he looks great this
technology is amazing also we see a
couple other MCU characters which will
mention later on in our MCU Easter Egg
section but let's mention Mitchell
Carson one of our villains for the movie
wow he is such a douche but originally
he appeared in Marvel team-up volume 3
number 21 in August of 2006 and he was
supposed to be the third official
ant-man but
then he ended up getting glass in the
face it gets a big scar on his face and
then Eric O'Grady takes the ant-man suit
and becomes the pervy ant-man I am NOT a
fan of Erik O'Grady he watches women in
the shower we're then introduced to
Scott Lang who first appeared in
Avengers number 181 in March of 1979 now
in the comics it's pretty similar to the
MCU he's a thief he's an electronics
expert and he steals a suit from Hank
Pym to use to try to save his sick
daughter now that's where the stories
differ just a little bit from the comic
k in the movie but moving on let's talk
about San Quentin prison which is a real
prison but also worth mentioning that in
the Ultimate Universe the punisher
spends some time there after
accidentally killing spider-man hey you
know Peter Parker it's a dark story also
let's give a shout out to Michael Pena
who plays Lewis in this movie he is
amazing also a big fan of the other
crooks that work with ant-man and Lewis
even though they are kind of stereotypes
but they also are original creations for
this movie they have no you know origins
from the comics but what's not original
is Darren cross he first appeared in
Marvel premiere number 47 in April 1979
now he is way over the top and they do
try to explain it because the fopen
particles are kind of messing with his
brain chemistry but this movie doesn't
really dive into that at all we also get
a nod to that with Hank saying that he
can't use a suit anymore because it
affect his brain chemistry that's
actually why in the comics it's
explained why he hit his wife moving on
we do see hope Van Dyne who is in the
comics but it's kind of complicated her
appearance is an 8 next number 7 in
April 1999 so relatively new now
originally she was created in an
alternate reality she is the daughter of
Hank and Janet but she actually grows up
to become a villain aka the Red Queen
but moving on from that we see the
Yellow Jacket armor which first appeared
on Hank Pym in Avengers number 59 in
December of 1968 now the powers are very
similar to the ant-man suit and the old
jacket suit in the comics are pretty
much the same in the movie but I feel
like this is actually a fun connection
to Erika Grady and that's why Carson
kind of plays a role in this now bear
with me but originally Eric O'Grady's
costume has arms similar to the iron
spider
suit and the Yellow Jacket costume in
this has the little arms that have the
stingers on it which there are stingers
on the Yellow Jacket costume in the
comics we then run into Cassie Lang
Scott's daughter who is from the comics
and she's actually a very prominent hero
now she first appeared in Marvel
premiere number 47 April 19
and she does take on a number of
different personas specifically aunt
girl giant girl stinger and stature
moving forward we get our MCU ant-man
suit which I actually prefer to the
comic accurate suit also shot up to the
first time it's cot shrinks in the
bathtub I do want to point out that
shrinking in a bathtub or mainly a sink
and then getting washed down the drain
and running into a rat is one of
ant-man's first adventures when he
shrinks also we run into one of the
flying ants and Scott Lang gets on top
of it which is ant man's famous mode of
transportation in the comics he's done
it in the past he doesn't present it's
awesome also we get a few knots to
subatomic or the quantum realm which is
usually called the Microverse in the
comics that regulator is compromised you
would go subatomic
what does that mean it means that you
would enter a quantum realm I kind of
hope they call it the Microverse in the
antman and the wasp movie but it is cool
that they mentioned it it's just a
universe that exists once you shrink
down far enough there's even people
there and other alien races very funny
also I think we get a not to hope being
a villain in the comics with this scene
right here where she's testing out the
ant control module on her ear and this
leads us to the wasp explanation where
is Janet now here's a quick backstory on
her she first appeared in tales to
astonish number 44 and she's a founding
member of the Avengers and she is
similar to Hank being that she can
shrink but she is different where she
has wings and blasters which seems like
the smart thing to do it man come on you
ride a flying ant
put some wings on yourself it'll help
you get around moving forward - the
Falcon ant-man fight that's really cool
that we actually get to see the red
goggles from the Falcons costume that
are in the comics and then scooting
forward we don't really get any more at
Comic Book Easter eggs until the first
post-credits scene with the wasps
costume it's very cool that we get some
cues of yellow there which we don't see
now in the man and the wasp costume it's
more grey but you do get some of the
signature yellow that is part of wasps
costume in the comics that's enough for
comic book Easter eggs let's move on to
any see you Billy is kicking it off with
the opening to the movie we see the
Triskelion being built which we first
saw in Captain America Winter Soldier
which is from the comics it first
appeared in the Ultimate Universe now
it's in the main comic universe as well
we also get to see Peggy Carter on my
favorite characters in the MC of course
we last saw her in Avengers age of
Ultron in that weird Captain America
dreamy thing that he had but also let's
give a shout out to the Marvel 2.0 logo
which I'm a big fan of also if I
remember correctly this is the last time
we end up
seeing it but anyways let's give a shout
out to Louis's introduction with this
scene so good and then after Scott gets
fired from baskin-robbins if you noticed
the poster in the background that's
actually a drink company that we saw
Bruce Banner working for in his solo
Hulk adventure it's bingo Dolce also
later we see Hanks keys and on that
keychain we see the tank which later on
is using them we don't worry I'll bring
it up moving forward we see this random
guy looking menacing in a deleted scene
we actually see that he has a ten rings
tutu on his neck ten rings is the
villainous terrorist organization that
we saw in the Iron Man franchise very
cool that there's a nod to them in this
movie or there was going to be but
deleted scene I didn't want to point out
during Scott's first shrinking scene he
shrinks from the middle of his body
instead of shrinking down which he
normally does throughout the rest of the
movie they're moving forward to his
jailhouse breakout scene on the flying
ant for the very first time if you
notice this newspaper this random person
is holding it says sokovia right there
which is a fun not - avengers age of
ultron them dropping a city there's also
another nod to Avengers age of Ultron
but later on then scooting forward to
Hank and Scott talking about ant-man and
what he's done with the ant-man suit and
him wanting Scott to be the new ant-man
you notice in the background you
actually see a breakdown of the ant-man
helmet on the wall also we get a shout
out to the Avengers right here I think
our first move should be calling the
Avengers and that's where you get your
other age of Ultron nod they're moving
forward to one of our final
confrontation scenes we get a nod to
Hydra the representatives of Hydra
they're not what they were they're doing
some interesting work it's gonna
actually be a fun not to the agents of
shield TV show because after the events
of Winter Soldier they went on the
offensive against Hydra as well also
want to point out here Carson is running
away with a sample of the fake Pym
particles maybe this is a hint to ghost
our villain in ant-man and the wasp
because if you notice during this scene
there's kind of a yellowish hue to ghost
as she's kind of phasing a little bit
also the tank on the keychain scene does
pay off here at the end but I don't
think a tank could survive a fall like
that and then I got to point out the
final nod to Empire Strikes Back during
phase 2 of the MCU the first body part
that Darren cross ends up losing when he
starts shrinking in on himself is his
arm which is a nod to Luke losing his
arm and Empire Strikes Back this has
happened in every single phase to MCU
movie if you watch all my other
breakdowns but I didn't
point out during the shrinking scene
where Scott is going subatomic there's a
few random flashes of a figure which has
later been confirmed to be the wasp
because it cuts between Scott's mask and
then her figure and some wings but
anyways let's skip to the final tip
scene from Louise and there's a bunch of
fun Easter eggs in this scene as well
but we do hear a reference to a guy who
that jumps a guy that swings the guy
that crawls up walls we've got a guy who
jumps we got a guy who swings we got a
guy who close up the wall you gotta be
more specific which feels like an
obvious nod to spider-man but the
creative team behind this movie said
that this script was written way before
a Spider Man was going to be a part of
the MCU but hey who else is gonna be
also worth mentioning that the second
post-credits scene that we get is
actually a scene from Captain America
Civil War and it was directed by the
Russo brothers and even mentioned the
sokovia Court who knows if the Accords a
little bit but this is a very fun Easter
Egg that confirmed that ant-man was
going to pop up in that movie and he's
amazing and I can't wait to talk about
it but anyways enough of that let's do
some pop-culture references really quick
first up during the Baskin Robbins scene
if you notice Paul Rudd's nametag says
Jack which feels like a nod to Jack
Kirby one of the co-creators of the
ant-man character also a shout out to
two amazing comedians during this Baskin
Robbins scene the guy asking for a hot
pretzel is Johnny Pemberton and also
Dale Scott Lang's boss is Greg turkleton
they are hilarious but moving forward we
actually get unfund not to a Marvel
creator someone who worked on the
Avengers and a couple ant-man stories al
Milgram he is referenced here with the
Milgram Hotel that Scott is staying in
also we get a nod to Warren Ellis
because the president of this universe
is president Ellis also worth mentioning
that this random guy in a car that Scott
Lang falls on top of and then grows this
is actually Garrett Morris who was on
SNL for a stretch and he played ant-man
who hasn't got a fun nod to David
Copperfield in this scene right here
that's like some David Copperfield as
well as the Andy Griffith Show with the
whistling Joe don't don't whistle no
whistling it's not The Andy Griffith
Show also here's a shout-out to Thomas
the Tank engines very cool of the
company that owns that IP allowed them
to use it in this movie it was awesome
seeing him big also worth pointing out
we actually see the microorganism a
tardigrade as ant-man is shrinking into
the Microverse also shout-out to
youtuber and Ayakashi now does more
acting as well but it is very cool to
see some representation for you too in
these movies and finally of course a
Stan Lee cameo he is the bartender
during the ferry final Lewis tip scene
it's very cool to see him I'm glad he
was able to make it in this movie
or she's gonna make in this movie oh
okay not as bad as Avengers age of
Ultron or guardians the galaxy but that
was still a very fun movie to break down
which of these Easter eggs were your
favorite let me know in the comments
down below or on Twitter let's try out
Sam bash at this time huh that's me
tweet me your thoughts also if I miss
anything you can let me know you guys
love doing that it's always a blast make
sure you like this video comment down
below share it with all of your MCU pals
and subscribe for more breakdowns I'm
gonna be doing Captain America Civil War
next week but there's also a ton of
other Easter eggs breakdown things on
this channel like for West world or The
Walking Dead or Game of Thrones again
I'm Sam basher and I'll see you next
time